[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans l'émission au
point de vue je vous présente les deux
invités qui ont accepté d'y participer
christophe de voogd bonjour vous êtes
historien professeur de rhétorique et
des idées politiques et président du
conseil scientifique de la fondapol est
votre dernier ouvrage publié à la
fondapol réformer quel discours pour
convaincre également démocratie sous
tension mathieu soupière bonjour bonjour
car vous êtes consultant expert associé
à la fondation jean jaurès et auteur
avec notre confrère damien fleurot de
2022 la flambée populiste qui va sortir
le 2 septembre chez plon et qui est
attendu avec impatience par tous nos
téléspectateurs et internautes
alors voici les deux thèmes qui ont
retenu notre attention aujourd'hui gifle
macron at il eu raison de relativiser et
le deuxième thème les régionales de 2021
le rassemblement national peut-il gagner
une région alors premier thème c'est sur
cette fameuse gifle d'hier macron at il
raison de relativiser puisque rapidement
après l'incident de tain l'hermitage le
président de la république a tenu à en
minimiser la portée en dix ans dans le
dauphiné libéré d'hier tout va bien il
faut relativiser cet incident qui est je
pense un fait isolé
il ne faut pas que cela viennent
occulter le reste des sujets si
importants qui concernent la vie de
beaucoup et ce sont des propos qui ont
été relayés évidemment ce matin par le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent c'était sur europe 1
est un fait isolé parce que il ne faut
pas donner le sentiment que ce qui a été
fait par cet homme est représentatif de
la société où la population française y
compris d'une forme de colère de la part
d'une partie des français parce que oui
il ya des fois il ya des français qui
doutent ya des français qui sont en
colère mais qui savent exprime et cela
dans le cadre du débat et dans le cadre
du vote alors christophe devaux qu est
ce que le président a eu raison de
relativiser cette la portée de cet
incident écoutez c'est toujours en
matière de rhétorique et de politique on
le sait depuis aristote tout jugement et
un jugement de probabilité c'est à dire
qu'il a plutôt raison l'auteur je crois
qu'il a plutôt raison quand même on a
plutôt raison je dirais est justement
pour trois raisons la première c'est que
s'il avait accentué la chose il aurait
du même coup accentué l'humiliation le
côté le roi est nu
je savais que les corps du roi etc il
aurait accentué les humiliations il
aurait aussi accentuer l'impression que
le pays est dans le chaos et qui est le
chef de ce pays
c'est un set assez risqué et puis enfin
je crois qu'il a peut être retenue c'est
mon hypothèse la leçon de l'échec de la
dramatisation de la tribune des généraux
ou au contraire vous souvenez dans la
tribune de généraux le gouvernement
avait carrément annoncé le putsch de
mines en rappeler des sanctions alors et
d'autres avaient eu quant à mme tam et
on l'avait vu dans les enquêtes
d'opinion après ça ça n'avait rien donné
ça n'avait pas marché ça s'était plutôt
retourner contre le gouvernement donc je
pense que c'est bien la crau qui est un
fin politique sinon il serait pas
président de la république
emmanuel macron sans peut-être qu'il ne
faut pas jouer la carte de l'hyper
dramatisation dans une société déjà
hyper traumatisé d'accord
mathieu sous pierre gabriel talent dit
il ne faut pas donner le sentiment que
ce geste est représentatif de la société
voire d'une forme de colère vous êtes
d'accord avec lui je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui et je ne suis pas non
plus d'accord avec emmanuel la con quand
il dit il faut relativiser parce qu'en
réalité je trouve qu'il n'a pas
relativiser alors il n'a pas attisé non
plus mais il n'a pas relativiser
il a immédiatement condamné
immédiatement condamné les faits de
violence fluence verbale violences
physiques en politique et
tout le monde a suivi c'est dire qu'il y
a eu une condamnation unanime de tous
les bords politiques
hier le premier ministre lui-même devant
l'assemblée a parlé de sursaut
républicain
je sais plus quelle est la formule
m'enfin monde voilà les états tout le
monde a parlé de ça dans la classe
politique
tout le monde a condamné la gifle dans
la classe politique et le système
médiatique depuis 24 heures ne parle que
de ça ou à peu près donc personne n'a
relativiser dirais-je
en revanche et appartements ont dit que
il s'agit précisément d'un fait isolé
est ce que dit le président on ne le
relativiser pas on lui donne un
caractère d'exception
on dit que précisément ce qui s'est
passé sort de l'ordinaire est
exceptionnel donc je n'entre pas que ce
soir relativiser ensuite il faut
évidemment proportionnelle à faire on a
connu dans l'histoire des agressions
physiques de gouvernants bien plus dur
bien plus violente
on a connu des internautes des rigoles
des attentats on a connu des assassinats
donc là la gifle était pas très appuyé
elle n'était pas très forte mais elle
n'était pas si douloureuse que ça pour
celui qui l'a reçu donc voilà ça fait
longtemps que l'intégrité physique des
gouvernants est mise en cause
oui et plusieurs incidents wii vient de
avec nicolas sarkozy existe-t-il avons
pu citer mais plus je me souvenais d'une
visite de chirac
je sais plus dans les yvelines mais il
était embarqué par bédié à l'époque
c'était il ya une vingtaine je pense que
c'était peut-être pour la campagne de
2002 il s'était fait cracher dessus par
des jeunes
il s'était fait cracher dessus par des
jeunes c'est pas rien non plus en termes
d' humiliations élite et donc c'est une
affaire qui dure et qui dure depuis
longtemps donc je trouve que de cela
alors pardon sur juste urinent sur attal
week ont un talent dit ça n'est
représentatif de rien là pour le coup il
s'agit pas de dramatiser mais ça
n'aurait été représentative de rien si
l'agissement avait été le fait de
quelqu'un sorti de nulle part
or c'est quelqu'un qui s'en revendiquent
est tout à fait une appartenance
politique semble être quand même un
militant politique ou à tout le moins un
sympathisant d'une cause qui est
précisément celle qui s'opposent
frontalement à emmanuel macron oui elle
est le cri montjoie saint denis à bas la
macro nuit alors ça c'est même assez
folklorique en tout état de cause il
semble proche de l'extrême droite ce qui
n'a pas empêché au contraire marine le
pen immédiatement de condamner la sphère
et de la condamner de très ferme façon
pour bien montrer que l
pouvait en aucun cas cautionner
l'agissement de quelqu'un qui pouvait
politiquement se revendiquait proche
d'elle en même temps quand emmanuel
macron effectivement dit c'est un fait
isolé il faut relativiser
c'est une manière aussi de ne pas donner
trop d'importance à cet événement qui
pourrait gommer tout le reste de ses
visites parce qu'en fait qu'il entame un
tour de france parce qu'il veut dire des
choses aux français tout à fait il
faudrait pas que ce cette itinérance
n'ont pas nui maurienne mais présentiel
comme on dit aujourd'hui il faudrait
passer tant il me rend ce soit gâché
comme la salle d'itinérance mémorielle
rappelez-vous l'avait été par la
polémique sur tours de pétain et le
début on s'est toujours frappant le
début des gilets jaunes on nous dit
toujours que ça a commencé les premiers
les premiers hurlements protestation
direct au président ont été faites
durant l'été d'errance mémorielle début
novembre et où c'est que les gilets
jaunes comme si je crois à la mi
novembre s'ils me souviens bien
et donc là c'était un petit peu il y
avait un parfum qu'il faut absolument
éviter de reproduire il ya aussi autre
chose du point de vue de ce qu'on
appelle les taux c'est à dire la
personnalité du président il veut
souligner une force qu'il a réellement
il veut la mettre en avant
en réagissant comme ça alors relativiser
ou minimisés ou contextualiser peu
importe
en tout cas ne pas en lippert
dramatisant pas il veut montrer aussi
qu'il est en contrôle et d'ailleurs vous
avez vu que immédiatement après
l'incident
rebelote il veut et continue le cirage
des pinces comme on dit un don qu'il
veut montrer qu'il est en contrôle très
important qu'on est quand on est le chef
et il veut montrer aussi comment
dirais-je qu' il est en même temps ils
tirent maintenant le bénéfice de la
victime il est la victime de l'agression
mais ils ne surent exploite pas ça et ça
s'est montré une qualité morale si vous
voulez une qualité éthique vis-à-vis de
l'opinion qui est de l'ordre d'une
infinitésimale du subliminal
mais en fait ça passe bien je suis à peu
près certain que s'ils en restent là cet
incident lui sera profitable à alors
étudiant vous abordez un terme j'imagine
que vous nous entendez profitable au
sens opinion c'est à dire que les
français lui en son temps ce qui va
prendre deux points dans les sondages
vous partagez aussi cette opinion c'est
vrai que le fait qu'il ya une classe
politique unanime
ça va ça peut encourager les français a
aussi exprimé une opinion positive alors
suite de cet incident je pense plutôt ça
mais on voit bien que comme souvent
l'opinion est un peu schizophrène et que
à force d'avoir de lui avoir répété
qu'un homme politique était bon quand il
se situait à hauteur de baffes comme on
l'a beaucoup dit le gif met à portée de
gifles à portée de baffes qu'il était
bon quand il faisait ça et que par
ailleurs on raconte depuis très
longtemps que les hommes politiques
méritent des baffes puisqu'en fait il
s'agit de nos gouvernants ne sont qu'une
tripotée d'incompétents et de gens
corrompus
à force de dire ça à l'opinion forcément
de dire ça à une opinion qui par
ailleurs revendique de l'horizontalité
effectivement l'horizontalité ça permet
de gifler celui qui est en face on étale
on est de plain pied
évidemment ça crée sacré ça et en même
temps l'opinion est attaché à cet
horizon c'est à cette horizontalité là
mais encore très attachés à une forme de
verticalité du pouvoir de sacralisation
du pouvoir qui paraît parfois d'ailleurs
anachronique la société entière c'est
désacralisée mais en matière de pouvoir
on a quand même envie de croire que le
président de la république même en
république du monde est une sorte encore
de monarque de droit divin donc on est
partagé entre cette dimension divine
c'est cette dimension humaine et il ya
par ailleurs une dimension viriliste du
pouvoir qui perdure encore et donc
effectivement comme le disait christophe
un gouvernant qui se fait gifler c'est
un gouvernant qui est un millier donc
est-ce qu'à la fin c'est la victime avec
sa hauteur de vue moral qui l'emportent
ou est ce que c'est quand même celui qui
s'est fait gifler par le premier venu un
peu l'hurluberlu en plus parce que
briand on est quand même dans quelque
chose de folklorique un peu reculé mais
plutôt voilà ce que vous diriez que ce
geste est facilitée par les propos ou où
les gestes de certains politiques je
pense par exemple vous souvenez on a vu
on a vu ces images maintenant en revenir
de clémentine autain esther benbassa qui
sont deux élus de la république qui dans
une manifestation donné des coups de
poing une effigie d emmanuel macron est
ce que tout ça on participe du même
phénomène et l'encouragent
alors je vous citais par exemple
clémentine autain qui me semble-t-il
dans le camp de la france insoumise fait
partie de ceux qui sont dans une retenue
assez systématique pour ce qui est de la
violence verbale
là où jean luc mélenchon et quelques-uns
de ses épigones la cultive véritablement
dont je ne suis pas sûr que clémentine
autain illustre le mieux ce que ce que
vous voulez dire
en revanche je pense par exemple à
archamps françois ruffin qui avait quand
même à l'époque des gilet jaune s'était
adressée au président de la république
en disant dans une tribune vous êtes hi
hi hi hi hi et évidemment l'incitation à
la haine soit disant en réponse du
mépris de classe de nos élites
là pour le coup peut générer de la
violence prisé il ya une violence
verbale est pardon pardon qu'elle
s'ajuste la france insoumise n'a pas le
monopole de la violence verbale
je pense tout de même que l'extrême
droite dans ce pays agite depuis
longtemps même si encore une fois marine
le pen c'est dédiaboliser depuis
quelques années je pense que l'extrême
droite
je vis quand même sur un imaginaire qui
est fait de viol enjoué belgique et
verbales oui mais là justement c'est là
nous serons en désaccord parce que a
justement ce que fait bien marine le pen
s'est pas seulement une dédiabolisation
mais ce que j'appellerais mois plus tôt
une chiraquisation c'est à dire que l
sur tous les sujets on l'a vu justement
dans cette très bonne réaction hier
évidemment quand on veut être président
de la république on intéresse que la
fonction resterait les a créés et elle a
tout de suite compris et qu'il fallait
pas jouer là dessus alors que d'autres
avaient été on va dire le pape pas des
grandes voix mais il ya eu des voix beau
j'ai vu quand même des voix sur twitter
en l'occurrence de gens de la france a
soumises qui était plus + limites
notamment mélenchon qui ramenait la
chose son cas personnel
williams est rare donc donc le voyez il
ya ya ya quand même
actuellement il faut si on est honnête
c'est à dire si on regarde ce qui se dit
je dis pas le fondateur de la pensée
jeudi ce qui se dit depuis des mois
voire des années
marine le pen et ceux qui l'entourent
c'est-à-dire bardella c'est à dire on va
reparler tout à l'heure jacques gony
c'est-à-dire odoul ont un langage qui
n'est pas du tout un langage de violence
verbale je suis désolé par rapport à à
la france est soumise en tout cas la
partie 1 dont vous avez parlé qui est
quand même la partie la plus nombreuse
penser à danièle obono aussi pour celles
à corbières et se penser à rufin en
effet à mélenchon lui-même
marine le pen nous a pas fait un coup tu
as public c'est moi alors qu'elle ait eu
quelques ennuis judiciaires donc je
trouve
et attendez ciel est haut dans les
sondages ceci explique peut-être cela
c'est à dire qu'elle se dont seulement
elle se dédiaboliser j'aime pas du tout
cette expression mais elle jure acquise
et voilà elle se chiraquisme carrément
c'est à dire qu'elle se rapproche parle
toujours de la séduction deux derniers
de macron sur une partie de la droite
mais la séduction de marine le pen sur
l'autre partie de la droite vient aussi
du fait qu'elle est en train tout
simplement de se mettre dans une
rhétorique de droite assez classique et
sur un ton assez classique et on n'a pas
le temps d'en parler c'est pas le sujet
sur le programme et mais elle fait un
réalignement pour c'est très très habile
parce que mac ont fait la même chose au
centre-droit c'est à dire qu'ils
essayent tous les deux de prendre un
espace rhétorique et programmatique tel
qu'il sera trop tard pour le candidat de
droite
oui pour revenir dans la partie
effectivement c'était un sujet qu'on
avait abordé déjà ici mais comme qui est
à mon avis sera toujours d'actualité
alors donc on a vous a posé la question
de savoir est ce que emmanuel macron a
eu raison de relativiser la gifle d'hier
vous répondez oui à 66% et julien sur
youtube nous dit il faut craindre que
cette gifle ne lui fasse défaut kriss
kross
oui il a raison de relativiser la jfp
est faiblarde
on est loin d'un coup de poing alors je
sais pas si le coup de poing ou la jfa
c'est plus le geste qui que la
l'intensité peut-être dominique il ne
peut que minimiser car sinon il est
obligé d'admettre qu'il est grandement
responsable de la désacralisation de la
fonction
on a entendu ça aussi sur twitter déjà
10 ans il l'a bien mérité
au fond il n'a que ce qu'il mérite vous
d'y penser ça aussi il ya un moment où
tout état de cause dans les enquêtes
d'opinion il y à un décrochage de
l'opinion vis-à-vis des manuels macron
sur cette question de l'arrogance des
records on reproche quand même à
emmanuel macron une incarnation du
pouvoir qui est faite d'argon ce qui est
fait de mépris de classe ça ça joue
encore dit entraînent ces agacements
conduire là l'opinion reprocher
énormément de choses à françois hollande
qui a au même moment était infiniment
plus bas en termes de popularité
mais il ne suscitait pas la même m alors
précisément parce que encore une fois
emmanuel macron à jouer la présidence la
présidence jupitérienne la verticalité
du pouvoir
quand ça marche vous inspirer le respect
du jour où ça s'inverse vous inspirer la
m
là où précisément françois hollande
quand même joué plutôt l'horizontalité
le président normal quand ça marche
inspiré de la sympathie le jour où ça se
retourne vous inspirer du mépris voilà
donc c'est quand même assez différent
comme resort vous êtes intéressé c'est
vrai un peu les mêmes phénomènes aussi
de haine alors on a comparé qui soupèse
pas exactement des mêmes personnes
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant pas du tout
pas pas des mêmes personnes puisque
sarkozy est resté plutôt aimé on va dire
tout son coeur de dans le peu de classes
moyennes et populaires
on va dire de souche commandes tandis
que macro est détesté par ces gens là
maintenant on voit très bien très très
nette différence et on sait que ce genre
d'offre ne voteront jamais macron il fut
bref alors qu'il pouvait très bien voter
sarkozy alors qu'ils ont voté sarko
nouveauté c'est qu'ils ont fait
d'ailleurs son succès son art le succès
en 2007 le traîneau au deuxième tour
donc mais il avait notamment dans la
classe alors là c'est l'inversé de macro
sea dans la classe va dire médiatico
politique
carlos lage sarkozy ce système une
véritable reine et j'entendais récemment
de vos collègues qui disaient oui c'est
très différent
sarkozy n'a jamais été aussi et je me
souviens très bien du titre je crois que
c'était de l'ops ou de marianne je sais
plus le voyou de la république c'est pas
si mal dans le genre violence verbale
c'était la balle et c'était vraiment on
sentait que sarkozy suscité c'était m
qui d'ailleurs a fini par l'emporter
pardon christophe faisait pas référence
à la même chose nicolas sarkozy sera
peut-être blanchi à la fin mai ils
portent quand même autour de lui un
certain nombre de boules et judiciaire
dont on ne peut pas accabler ni françois
hollande qui lui a succédé ni
aujourd'hui à manama conquête au pouvoir
tant que citoyen de la république
j'attends tes président à ransart
docteur de fonction pour savoir quelle
sera leur destin je dis cela pour
françois hollande
à ce stade on sait où il n'ya pas de
passer la main de casseroles
manifestement alors wait and see
on ne me fera pas sur ce terrain là mais
en revanche je rebondisse sur ce que
vous parliez du vote donc ça nous ouvre
le deuxième thème de notre débat sur les
régionales le rassemblement national
peut-il gagner une région alors pourquoi
on se pose cette question c'est parce
que les sondages se suivent et et
montrent une tendance identique qui est
un rassemblement national qui sera très
fort au premier tour alors on le voit
dans les tableaux que vous allez avoir
notamment en provence-alpes-côte d'azur
en bourgogne franche comté en grand est
alors là vous voyez dans les hauts de
france
le second tour
s'il y a une cadre angulaire est à
égalité entre xavier bertrand et
sébastien chenu égalité aujourd'hui avec
la marge d'erreur dans les sondages
vous pouvez très bien avoir un inconnu
qui l'emportent
c'est le même cas en provence alpes côte
d'azur où vous avez un sondage toujours
ipsos qui donne thierry mariani soutenu
par le rassemblement national vainqueur
51 % devant renaud muselier qui lui pour
le court n'aurait pas été soutenu par
par les écologistes et donc on a toutes
ces régions qui peuvent éventuellement
basculer je vous propose d'écouter
également ce que disait la députée
aurore bergé de la république en marche
c'était sur europe 1 le dimanche dernier
on ne les voit jamais ce sont des gens
qui ne sont pas des élus de terrain
les conseillers régionaux du
rassemblement national ils sont jamais
sur les wii joue par les électeurs qui
seraient tentés par le oui mais les
électeurs doivent aussi savoir quand on
prétend en permanence défendre les
français
il faut aussi être bon moment pour les
défendre il faut aussi être sur le
terrain pour les défendre il faut pas
uniquement et dans la petite phrase faut
pas uniquement et dans la dénonciation
alors christophe de vote si vous aviez
un pronostic à faire pour le 27 juin et
le nombre de régions qui basculerait
vous diriez quoi alors là quand je vous
dis la rhétorique c'est la probabilité
je vais d'abord vers une petite remarque
pour réagir aussi à ce que d'erreurs
berger qui très justement fait une
observation sur un monde que connaît
bien mathieu qui est le monde de des
élus locaux
c'est certain que
visiblement elle doit elle doit savoir
ce qu'elle dit mais l'absentéisme des
élus pour contre le rassemblement
national je peux vous dire que c'est un
argument qui pèsera très peu pourquoi
parce que le mouvement est national
quand vous regardez les sondages sur le
régional au niveau national qu'est ce
qu'on voit on voit une montée constante
du front national du rassemblement
national décidément les républicains se
tiennent bien
et désolé la gauche ça va pas fort et et
la république en marche à ne va pas fort
elle a perdu 5 points en quelques mois
sur l'ensemble de la france donc on va
quand même on est quand même très près
du but si j'ose dire on va donc vers une
élection où je crois qu'on peut on peut
on peu probable en probabilité sauf
encore une fois dame fortune comme
disait machiavel et un une invasion
chinoise
on peut quand même prédire que ce sera
un bon scrutin pour la droite ce sera un
bon scrutin pour la droite qui va gagner
quand même c'est à peu près certain et
l'ile-de-france conserver le conserver
je veux dire et ayez rendent rhône alpes
je pense que ce sera que je vois mal
comment le front national ne pourrait
pas gagner une région au moins mais qui
est cette région c'est pas car c'est par
mathieu soccer vous quel est votre
pronostic
alors mon pronostic va être forcément
prudent le front national est un parti
qui depuis 2002 arrive régulièrement au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est une force politique
nationale du première de première
importance
il n'empêche que c'est une force
politique qui n'a jamais réussi la
moindre implantation locale aux
municipales elle y ait un tout petit peu
parvenu mais de façon totalement
résiduelles elle a deux villes de taille
significative dans son escarcelle pour
le reste elle ne pèse rien au plan local
et je dirais même que c'est une de ses
faiblesses comme le dire hors berger
elle n'a plaindre elle n'a pas une
implantation locale
elle n'a pas d'appareil de maillage de
terrain et elles mêmes faibles sur ses
cadres
elle est en général assez marine le pen
est assez faiblement entouré aux
régionales aux dernières régionales on
se souvient que l approche du scrutin
quatre régions quatre régions devaient
tomber dans l'escarcelle du front
national d'ailleurs je ne sais plus si
tu es puisque c'était pas la même car tu
sais pas même si c'est une bonne franche
comté et grands c'est exact marine le
pen
dans les hautes france et en particulier
dans les hauts de france la victoire de
marine le pen elle même semble être
acquise et en paca
marion maréchal-le pen était également
très très très haut dans les sondages
plus de 40%
ça y'est mariani il est à 41 oui oui
mais donc en 2015 alors que tout le
monde pronostiquait plusieurs régions
pour le rassemblement national il le
pavillon national à l'époque ils n'ont
ils n'ont pas gagné mais il ya eu le
front républicain
toute la question nous sommes
entièrement d'accord est ce qu'il y aura
un franc de poser les questions
alors y aura-t-il médiatis beau temps
dit il ya par ailleurs deux dimensions
il ya le front républicain tel qu'il
s'opère du côté des du côté des
politiques des représentants politiques
et il ya par ailleurs ce que l'opinion
fait car est ce que l'opinion et mûri
pour élire en particulier en paca comme
le dit christophe l'extrême droite
alors c'est peut-être la région la plus
mûre pour ce qui est de la bascule est
les murs parce que c'est un bastion
politique historique de l'extrême droite
on peut dire quelle crème 2 front
national le front nationaux de
rassemblements nationaux en france il ya
celui du nord plus populaires et les
davantage tournés sur la question
sociale
et puis il ya celui du sud qui
historiquement est élevé le l'extrême
droite identitaire l'extrême droite
identitaire c'est probablement l'endroit
où la bascule vers le cloud et surtout
que mariani n'est pas moi je connais un
peu cette région
mariani n'est pas identifiée du tout
comme un quelqu'un d'une extrême droite
et surtout pas de la galaxie le pen
absolue mais pour cause il a fait sa mue
ya peu de temps pour les gens qui ont
parlé un électeur de droite en paca
lambda mariani c'est quelqu'un de la
maison rien et ça c'est un ancien
ministre de nicolas sarkozy devant ses
traits fins personnelles est très
important alors très important c'est que
c'est un bon candidat
ça compte aussi quand même c'est à dire
quand même dans mon domaine qu'est la
rhétorique vous mettez mariani face à
muselier je suis désolé mais c'est le
cas actuellement
nadal face à charlemagne si vous voulez
donc il n'y a pas photo et ça il ya un
coefficient personnel mais écoutez moi
j'ai vu les chiffres ils montent sans
cesse et plus ça va plus il monte en
fait le seul cas de figure où il est
menacé on vient de le voir où c'est un
certain mais vraiment incertain
c'est si la gauche se retire alors
je me posais une question quand on
connaît la vie politique française
notamment le fait d'être élu ou pas élu
est ce que vous croyez qu'en paca et
dans le nord les toute la gauche va
accepter pour six ans de plus de n'avoir
aucun élu au conseil régional
c'est très bon et c'est des carrières
ben c'est des crédits c'est du maillage
c'est du réseau est-ce qu'on peut alors
moi je sais que la gauche à l'esprit
sacrificielle pour ça comme dit luchini
que j'ai moi j'ai pas cette force morale
mais est ce qu'elle peut risquer la fin
on gagne c'est à dire se dire pendant
six ans je continue à regarder les
trains passer avec tout ce que ça veut
dire en employons la politique suisse
etc du job si je rajoute un violon s'il
a moins d'un an de la présidentielle
absolument c'est parce que c'est pas de
temps en fait c'est toute la question
est ce que donc est-ce que je renonce à
mes ressources locales ou est-ce que je
renonce à mes à mes valeurs et surtout
effectivement on est à un an du scrutin
la fondation dont le rsa a publié il ya
quelques semaines une note d'antoine
bristiel qu'il y bien que la victoire de
marine le pen à la présidentielle de
l'année prochaine est possible elle est
possible parce qu'elle a réussi sa dé
diabolisation ou chirac isation comme le
dit christophe elle a réussi ça elle est
possible parce qu'il ya une porosité
inédite entre l'électorat de droite
classique et l'électorat d'extrême
droite
à force raison à fortiori en paca
absolument et troisième dimension elle
est possible parce que le rejet des
manuels macron peut être supérieure au
rejet de marine le pen est-elle probable
cette victoire elle est possible et elle
probable pas encore pas encore mais ça
change tout si on lui donne de l'élan
régional ter que si pour la première
fois l'implantation locale et la
légitimité locale qui lui fait défaut
lui est accordé sur un plateau donc je
pense que la gauche en dépit du franc
qu'elle ronge depuis plusieurs années
dans certaines régions je pense que la
gauche commettrait une erreur historique
majeur majeur si elle ne paierait pas un
front républicain à un an d'une
présidentielle qui va se jouer dans un
climat qui n'a jamais été aussi délétère
qu'aujourd'hui et je pense que si la
victoire de marine le pen est
aujourd'hui possible
elle peut devenir probable si une ou
plusieurs régions
alors gilles agit évidemment d'une
répétition de la présidentielle alors
juste pour associer nos internautes ceux
qui nous suivent à notre débat donc on
leur avait posé là on vous avait posé la
question leur haine at il une chance de
gagner une région lors des prochaines
élections régionales
vous dites oui à 79% rejoignant ce que
nous pensons sur la foi des sondages
mais encore une fois qu'ils sont qu'une
photographie on va voir ce que diront
les électeurs babineau nous dit le rn
peut l'emporter avec marianne il faut
relativiser les sondages de premier tour
avec le retrait des listes au second
tour effectivement toute la question est
là
gisèle je pense que rennes a ses chances
par contre il faudrait se renseigner sur
la gestion de quelques mairies décroché
par le rn ça donnerait déjà un aperçu de
ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
ces baisses ont réélu de façon massive à
chaque fois non là ça s'est fini cette
histoire de la gestion des coûts il
savait est vrai autrefois hainard a été
réélu haut la tour et olam a prévu pour
la centrale et à béziers vous comprendre
sébastien sur youtube
cet acte montre le mécontentement des
français contre la politique de macron
ce qui amène cette question au fond si
une ou deux régions basculent aux arènes
ça sera la faute de qui voit là sa part
est au moins aussi important que le
destin de la gauche qui encore une fois
moi je comprends très bien mais il ya
une question de devoir mais aussi une
question d'intérêt est aussi bien bien
compris d'être absent sans arrêt d'une
élection c'est pas bon non plus pour les
élections nationales festieux mais sur
la république en marche et je crois
qu'on sera d'accord
mathieu là dessus c'est peut-être ça le
plus grand enjeu c'est à dire j'ai
remarqué que dans plusieurs régions une
majorité de régions en fait ça va être
l'arbitré du second tour la république
en marche alors elle est très mal placé
ce qui est sûr c'est que je crois
qu'elle n'aura aucune région ce
peut-être s'en fout mal de rôles de
noirs d'accord et on s'est serré la
gauche les lieux la gauche est mieux
parti et leur assemblée nationale est
mieux parti
là encore intelligence de marine le pen
elle a choisi aussi de bons candidats
des candidats qui sont d'abord une
nouvelle génération pas marqué par tous
et qui sont avenants et parler qui parle
encore une fois correctement donc voir
brillamment pour bardella par exemple
non je pense que ça va être un vrai
problème
j'avais écrit un article dans le figaro
d'ailleurs là-dessus je comprends pas le
choix en haut de france
en paca je crois que c'est une erreur
mais à la limite pouvait se dire bon on
va créer un mouvement
on va dire ump met dans les roues de
france qu'est ce qu'ils ont à gagner à
la république en marche c'est
perdant-perdant soit bertrand est élu ce
qui est pas bon pour le président
puisque ça lui donne la vapeur pour pour
l'année prochaine soit le républicain
championnat national est élu ce qui est
une catastrophe quand on la voit dans
tous les cas de figure cinq ministres
combat c'est à dire espagnols - pascal
dupont moretti
mais c'est des tranchées à nouveau c'est
à dire qu'on sait nivelles c'est
l'offensive nivelle
on envoie cinq ministres au casse pipe
mais je viens de voir les derniers
sondages non seulement ça prend pas mais
ça même plutôt tendance à plomber la
liste dans le nord l etat disque n'a pas
vraiment bougé disons oui alors elle et
elle est plutôt à 17,2 à 12 yahia zoubir
semaine dernière oui ça déborde fait un
si bref le sec ce qui veut dire qu'ils
peuvent la mettre
éliminés comment est ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir dicter à monsieur bertrand leurs
conditions s'ils sont éliminés ou s'ils
sont à 10%
non effectivement où on a évoqué le rm
on a évoqué la république en marche mais
il ya une question que christophe devaux
que vous a posé est prévu de vous poser
aussi sont passés les électeurs de
gauche c'est eric quand vous voyez les
sondages en auvergne rhône-alpes
najat vallaud belkacem et à 10 11% -
alors deux choses par rapport à ça la
fondapol à a produit une excellente
étude il ya quelques semaines quelques
mois je sais plus quand sur la
droitisation de l'europe c'est à dire
qu'on a un phénomène de gaz y allons il
ya un phénomène de droitisation qui
n'est pas propre à la france
on voit bien que tous les indicateurs
montrent que dans les dans les
démocraties libérales européennes
la droite a le vent en poupe alors
l'extrême droite le national en
république mais aussi mais la droite a
le vent en poupe alors oui nos électeurs
de gauche mais nos effectifs sont alors
partis au front national
non oui mais ça les candidats je crois
pas ils se sont mis un certain nombre
sont partis à la france est soumise à un
certain nombre sont partis chez chez
manuel mcneill c'est sûr et en tout état
de cause il est évident que le
quinquennat de françois hollande s'est
terminée de telle façon que quatre ans
après la gauche n'est pas remise
c'est incontestable c'est dire que je
repars remise elle la gauche en 2012 en
disposait de tous les pouvoirs
1 tous les pouvoirs comme historiquement
elle n'en avait jamais disposé sous la
vème république le sel a rendu les clés
du cal
cinq ans après en n'ayant absolument
tout perdu un président dans
l'incapacité de se représenter un
premier ministre perd la primaire doit
d'ailleurs s'interroger pourquoi avec le
soutien en fait un excellent vivante du
quinquennat hollande je n'ai pas de
doute sur le fait que la gauche se pose
la question et que la gauche souffre de
son incapacité à remonter la pente
quand une défaite est aussi sénat mais
hélas oui mais la vraie question c'est
pas fou c'est pourquoi on perd c'est pas
la question de savoir pourquoi on ne se
remet pas d'une défaite alors ce que je
vous propose c'est que cela ouvre un
second débat mais par ailleurs
aujourd'hui parce que d'abord les stocks
revient veut voir la suite du match
nadal et que nous il faut qu'on rendre
l'antenne parce que il y à part dont
j'en perds mon stylo en plus un autre
débat qui va falloir suivre sur notre
antenne c'est le débat dans les hauts de
france qui retransmis sur rtl et lci
mais également sur notre site internet
donc ce fameux débat des régionales avec
les principaux candidats et un débat
animé par david pujadas avec la
participation d'yves treacy chenu
gagnants dans les hauts de france
nous allier bertrand sort donc là aussi
ça rebat les cartes de façon
considérable pour la présidentielle ce
n'est pas l'hypothèse la bulle robe
selon le sondage
on voit qu'ils sont à égalité si jamais
il ya une cadre angulaire à ce que je
ferai une triangulaire absolue bertrand
passe plus facilement
merci à vous de votre participation
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et à
bientôt
merci
on
[Musique]